and a new warning from our other energy
company we're talking about envy energy
company leaders saying that a number of
complaints are coming in about scammers
offering rooftop solar and even rebates
one valley resident speaking to
christian casares about how he received
a call but was able to outsmart the
thieves
i had someone cold call me ask if i was
interested in putting solar
on my residence las vegas resident matt
kimball says it takes a lot to scam him
but the fake calls are getting more
convincing it's a great way to uh to
save some money on your energy bill
but the problem is like it wasn't an nv
energy person calling me i had no idea
who they were it's the latest scam that
has nv energy's phones ringing non-stop
their spokesperson telling 8 news now
scammers are saying they are part of the
electric company to sell solar around
the valley they
pretty much were trying to either sell
me something or gain access to my place
of residence
which seemed a little odd for it to me
kimball says some red flags for him was
an old address they had and the person
on the phone was very persistent and the
energy is hoping this warning on social
media can help its customers be wary
also nv energy doesn't call customers to
demand immediate payment they also don't
accept payments via venmo or bitcoin
employees are prohibited from accepting
payments while in the field finally
service calls are by appointment only i
was not going to disclose to them that
you need to update your database because
you have the wrong address let them play
along with me and waste some of their
time honestly christian casa is live
local now envy energy also reminding its
customers that they don't partner with
solar providers we have more tips on how
to avoid these types of scams on our
website you'll find that at
eightnewsnow.com